- La saison de la construction
est lancée et s'annonce
bien remplie pour cette
entreprise qui construit ici
des immeuble de six logements.
STÉPHANE LATOUR
président, Gestion ADG
- Les défis sont là, puis
grands, on essaye
de venir à bout de tout ça.
Je dirais que j'ai des immeubles
qui retardent environ de
deux mois, il y en a d'autres,
c'est un mois, tout dépendant.
- Alors que la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre ralentit déjà
la cadence sur les chantiers,
s'ajoute la difficulté
d'obtenir certains matériaux,
comme les portes,
les fenêtres, les poutrelles
et les foit.
- Avant, fermes de toit,
on parlait d'environ trois
semaines à un mois maximum.
Aujourd'hui, il faut placer
une commande, puis si on place
on a ça fin novembre.
- Les usines n'arrivent pas
à répondre à la demande.
Encore une fois, le manque
de personnel est en cause.
RICHARD DARVEAU, prés. Ass. qu.
quinc. et matériaux construction
- Ce manque de main-d'oeuvre
vient déduire la quantité de
matériaux qui sont disponibles,
qui sortent des manufactures
ou qui sortent de9
[éOtati=k9
- Un effet de rareté qui fait
grimper les prix.
Et la hausse des cours du
pétrole n'aide pas les choses.
- Que ce soient des colles,
des lubrifiants, des peintures,
l'ensemble des matières
plastiques qu'on retrouve
dans l'industrie entre autres
des portes et fenêtres, mais
pas seulement là-dedans,
ça va contenir du pétrole.
- Conséquence : le prix
des maisons neuves a explosé
en deux ans.
PAUL CARDINAL, Ass. prof.
construction et habitation, Qc
- On est à 18 % par rapport à la
même période l'année dernière.
on est entre 30 et 35 %.
- Pour se protéger de la hausse
des coûts des matériaux,
Stéphane Latour conclut
des ententes qui contiennent
un mécanisme d'ajustement des
prix. Les clients úti@ú  sPX
leur contrat il y a un an voient
donc leur facture grimper.
- Environ 15 % d'augmentation
sur le bâtiment total. On suit
le marché, puis c'est des
"cost-plus", toutes les factures
sont à l'appui,
pourcentage à la fin.
MARC-ANDRÉ HARNOIS, dg, Ass.
cons. qualité de la construction
- Il faut que le consommateur
sache au moment où il signe son
contrat ce à quoi ils'engage.
- Les clients doivent être
vigilants, dit l'Association des
consommateurs pour la qualité
dans la construction.
- On a vu des cas où par exemple
un entrepreneur construit deux
maisons pareilles l'une à côté
re, et les deux clients
n'ont pas la même hausse
de prix.- Près de 78 000 mises
en chantier ont été effectuées
dans le secteur résidentiel
l'an dernier au Québec,
un niveau inégalé depuis
plus de 30 ans. Ce nombre
devrait baisser à 55 000
cette année, selon l'APCHQ.
Le bassin d'acheteurs rétrécit
en raison de la hausse des prix.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-C